Kylo Ren the Star Wars sequels' resident bad
boy and dark side-abider played by Adam Driver
has walked a dangerous path in The Force Awakens
and The Last Jedi, and will continue taking
what he believes is rightfully his by whatever
means necessary in the upcoming film The Rise
of Skywalker.
But Kylo will need more than his angsty attitude,
hilted lightsaber, inexplicably high-waisted
pants, and the burning desire to emulate his
late grandfather Darth Vader to get where
he wants to go.
He'll need a ship a big one, a stealth one.
Thanks to a photo of a yet-to-be-released
The Rise of Skywalker toy obtained by Twitter
user @_selenejade, we now know what model
of ship Kylo Ren will pilot in The Rise of
Skywalker and the name seems to offer some
pretty juicy hints about what the baddie might
get up to in the film.
Here's your one and only warning, friends:
turn back now if you don't want to learn any
spoilers for The Rise of Skywalker.
We can't exactly Jedi mind trick them out
of your memory.
As seen on the packaging for the new Kylo
Ren Funko Pop figure, scheduled to hit shelves
on Triple Force Friday on October 4th, the
villain will get behind the helm of a TIE
Whisper in The Rise of Skywalker.
The TIE Whisper looks to be a riff on the
TIE Fighter and TIE Interceptor ships, both
favorites of the Galactic Empire.
It features a spherical black hull accented
with the same shade of red that Kylo Ren's
lightsaber glows, and four foreboding, round
wings.
What's important to note about this new information
isn't so much the model name itself but what
"TIE Whisper" suggests about Kylo Ren's behavior
and motives in The Rise of Skywalker.
Specifically, "Whisper" implies that Kylo
may take a new approach to battle in the upcoming
film.
In The Force Awakens and The Last Jedi, Kylo
had no problem killing, resorting to violence,
and being about as bold and brash as any larger-than-life
villain can be.
That may all be because that's just who Kylo
has become since abandoning his family, the
light side of the Force, and his birth name
Ben Solo to align with the First Order, or
it might be because he's actively trying to
do what he believes his grandfather would
have done in order to gain some semblance
of importance.
In any case, Kylo has been unapologetically
bombastic over the course of the last two
Star Wars movies, and that's cost him a few
things.
Kylo lost his father at his own hand and a
good chunk of his face in a fight, broke his
beloved helmet, had his confidence knocked
down a few pegs in lightsaber duels with Rey,
and was finally put in his place in a jaw-dropping
battle against Luke Skywalker, who, it turns
out, had been Force-projecting in order to
help the Resistance escape from the First
Order.
Despite Kylo's best efforts, and in the face
of great adversity, the Resistance is growing
stronger even with diminishing numbers.
Kylo may very well realize in The Rise of
Skywalker that he must be stealthy and go
undetected if he hopes to achieve his ultimate
goal of total galaxy domination.
But what exactly will Kylo Ren do in The Rise
of Skywalker, and why does he need a new ship
to get it done?
Isn't his personal TIE Silencer, a nod to
Darth Vader's own TIE advanced ship, enough?
"Clear your mind of questions.
Mmmm…
Mmmm..."
Well, according to the description of a new
Kylo Mattel Black Series figure, he will continue
to, quote, "search for secrets of the Force
from the depths of the dark side" in The Rise
of Skywalker.
Given that his tactics have been hit-or-miss
in the past, it stands to reason that Kylo
would want to ensure success by being a little
more sly this time around which is something
that his fancy shmancy, souped-up TIE Silencer
can't exactly do what with all the, y'know…
laser cannons and missile launchers and whatnot.
Whether he'll be successful with a more stealthy
approach is another question, though recent
rumors claim that Kylo will ultimately be
completely crushed by the second act of The
Rise of Skywalker.
Allegedly, the struggles Kylo faces in the
new movie will lead his late father Han Solo
to appear to him in a vision, delivering him
a rousing message that spurs him to abandon
his Kylo Ren persona and turn to the light
side of the Force.
If that actually ends up happening, we hope
Kylo er, Ben Solo at least gets to keep his
cool new ship.
The Rise of Skywalker flies into theaters
on December 20th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.